[Música]
trago um livro da biblioteca livre é
feito o papel de fazer esse papel com
critérios de pagamentos cujo papel
vendas artigos e pode se perguntar se
começou a tirar o papel das áreas
primeiro papel foi feito dois séculos
antes de cristo
o fluminense foi algo extraordinário foi
uma mudança extraordinária e ainda mais
extraordinário ficou quando passados
cinco séculos
três delas está foram feitas as
primeiras impressões
o primeiro teste começaram a ser fixo em
papel da escrita antiga muito mais
antiga a evolução do homem pra história
história ea escrita vai com a história
era feita em pedra e barro piro chinesa
passou a ser feita escrita em tabela
criou-se o papel chegou à europa através
da imprensa américa com a seleção agora
corria o século ou serra que está chegou
aqui na ibéria coisa curiosa ainda as
francesas mas não tem papel agora tem
tanto papel moeda e nós já temos papel
aqui mas a imprensa não chegou
o site não trouxeram tudo e foi só no
século 15 anos quase maior que é a
imprensa deve ser reinventada na europa
no coração da europa da cidade mainz na
alemanha por bial anunciou ontem foram
podemos chamar as segundas intenções
foi uma revolução ainda mais
extraordinária do que aquela do papel e
da repressão chinesa porque para nós
pelo menos pessoas aqui para nós
mudou a civilização nós chamamos a
ocidental e vai mudar o mundo todo o
livro de facto é uma coisa
extraordinária e em poucos anos os
livros que eram pelos manuscritos feitos
nos fracos ficam verdes passaram a ser
impresso e elevados porque o livro é
portátil e um livro quando os facilmente
eu trouxer facilmente comigo e que
passaram rapidamente por todo ano
avançando que o tempo trouxe rapidamente
à europa chama 15 na dos meus livros de
século
este livro intitula-se cosmos saga está
um pouco usado no código está um pouco
mais ganhava era um que no estrato da
assistência da memória um capítulo de
livro saia a escrita foi a melhor das
invenções humanas ligando as pessoas que
dão da época distante que nunca ficaram
a conhecer os livros quebram as cadeias
do tempo provam que os seus humanos são
capazes e energia
liberato facto estranho mágico
permitidos ouvir atentamente alguém do
passado e é isso pessoal fazer os
autores antigos os autores modernos
passaram está omnipresente e passará a
ser possível ouvir álcool é um dos
livros mais vantajoso ou os sítios onde
os livros estão junto à biblioteca
especial que eu gosto muito porque
passei lá sete anos da minha vida foi o
dia mais feliz da minha vida quando eu
um dia
não é só coisas que acontecem e podem
acontecer terá um cinto e até já são
pedro me perguntar o que quiser da vida
para escolher disse ao inferno que é o
ensino que é preciso que também é um
livro e e eu quero eu vou dizer agora de
livros e guarde bem guardado
os livros que eu devolvi foram os livros
que eu recebi é é de facto mas até quem
chaia do tesouro
o tac que brilha aliás os turistas hoje
quando entram venha que o dourado todo e
business pensando em entrar numa igreja
facto em ver nossa senhora do lado do
joão pinto que é um pouco menos homem
por exemplo mas enfim estava aqui estava
no brasil
aliás eu acho que consigo fazer isso foi
cor do brasil cobrar bom quinto recebe
as quinto da sucessão dinástica mas é
também um quintal vez do ouro os padrões
do filho que hoje é muito generoso
é um sítio facto formidável fantástico
habitável
vim para o ecossistema variados
não só os turistas mas também os erros
estão lá então estas pinturas chinesas
outros motivos orientais porquê porque
biblioteca e um espelho do mundo eo
mundo português um montão joão que em
todo o mundo afinal brasil mas tinha
também a índia e china através de macau
e portanto é ex presos a biblioteca são
do módulo reflexo do mundo do cosmos
final na altura se falava português no
teto da biblioteca estava essa teoria
e digo-vos que eu já vi muito perto
delas torna a biblioteca do município ao
sítio onde os estudantes hoje estudam
alguns pelo menos é que não vemos ainda
porque
é é a cena quem sabe aí que embaixo a
festas noel os estudantes seguem aquela
basta imitar o remodelo que é seguir o
curso e 18
[Aplausos]
um dos livros mais preciosos da
biblioteca joanina é também um dos meus
livros as oficinas gutenberg estiver
verdadeiramente extraordinário está num
sítio tão discreto que não vos digo mas
pra mim o livro mais precioso da
biblioteca de coimbra tech dando certo
bíblia é isto porque só há um outro dá
alguns isso não é impresso é um
documento escrito pintado proteger um
dos volumes dos trunfos da índia estão
juntos gastou mostra uma espécie de
google maps argento feitos português
está em quebra a mão sem satélite do
tamanho da ciência
nesse tempo sexy eu saio joão quinto
andava a medir costa da índia é da raça
o mar é uma emoção que chamamos hoje
moção científica
essa revolução científica não teria sido
possível
sai os livros os livros foram os
veículos da evolução científica e um
livro revolucionário foi este saiu logo
no ano da morte de nicolau copérnico e
ainda viu o livro não pode é ver o
digamos a percepção de que o livro foi
vítima mas o livro assistiu
apesar da pesquisa ter outras edições e
teve que defender seu livro é este ano
de 1843 pode ser visto como o ano do
início da evolução científica outro
livro no mesmo ano que é o iniciante
sina andreev salvio o médico no site que
mostra pela primeira vez em belas
estampas no interior do corpo humano ao
mesmo tempo que sabia
ligamos o sistema do cosmos vias também
o interior do nosso corpo havia
portuguesa nesta história do
conhecimento do cosmos um deus garcia da
orta que estudou as plantas cidade da
índia e suas aplicações medicinais e
queimaram do sócio
enfim eu já não sentiu nada pedro nome
1.566
a neve na biblioteca e algo curioso um
deles são de copérnico é feita em
brasília nem mesmo a oficina do livro
pedro nunes próprias palavras publicadas
mil chips
o livro do cientista português é um
leilão online é o homem que defende
copiar e é perseguido por causa disso
ela cuidar da inquisição à prisão
perpétua em sua casa mesmo alguma coisa
que o fez em casa na prisão escreveu um
livro esse livro saiu clandestinamente e
vai ter a europa do norte na imprensa
seu manuscrito vai ter algo natural para
nem pressão e auxilia vivemos hoje um
tempo também o cenário não parece mas é
da polícia para a semana vou sair eu vi
no meu tempo o governo meu tempo é que o
tempo chamar uma nova versão do google
tem mérito
as primeiras impressões chinesa segundas
opções do tempo é que temos agora as
primeiras impressões que teve ao longo
da minha vida foi de fato extraordinário
foi das primeiras pessoas a comprar o
que o pessoal na universidade de coimbra
lembra de nove computadores ao ver
apenas omc eram um monstro não lembra da
gama da concentração que nós fazemos
pode apagar aquela imagem
lembro da guarda e do ep fui dos
primeiros pessoas a ligar digamos à
internet isto foi autos físicos fizeram
para comunicar entre si o estepe e tudo
incluído ti da vocês crianças
[Aplausos]
o mundo é hoje uma aldeia global os
servidores estejam onde estejam
não sabemos onde estão guardam os livros
modernos
a informação que vem anunciado hoje ter
conosco podemos ir às bibliotecas
há bons motivos para ir às bibliotecas
mas também mas também podemos ir às
bibliotecas com através dos telemóveis
através dos computadores por outras
palavras ele tem que ser preto às
bibliotecas ficaram em todo o lado
as bibliotecas são o vickers e por isso
é velho a universidade hoje está também
é que a biblioteca da universidade está
aqui pela fae podem se quiserem voz
telemóveis que ler completamente a
primeira sessão do filme diz pinto eles
a original não falar dos livros que a
mãe é o para vender todos os meus
artigos algo mais modesto todos os
brasileiros que estão na base da área
digital
enfim nunca mais o francisco não
imaginavam que a companhia que antes nos
seus escritos
hoje vive técnicas modernas estas chamas
roubo foi uma que eu criei não sabe que
ainda tem computadores e tem um livre
frente a frente e o próprio você
trabalha
eu tenho vários computadores e tem
também vários livros e é com seus
computadores complementar seus livros
livros não são inimigos dos computadores
são comprometer para entrar na bíblia de
gutenberg procurava imitar uma escrito
também é que os livros eletrônicos
procuro imitar o livro o livro não
morreu
às vezes a notícia da morte do livro por
exemplo esta biblioteca construída com
veículos ante aquela travar quem
confunde na flórida é é uma etec 100
livros sem livros que existem sem nenhum
livro não tem só sai não tenho esta
biblioteca é tem é é um escárnio orienta
e vai passar com baixa ocupação livros
eletrônicos é tenha luz que vai através
de digamos do teto e tem o o ordenado
haifisch espalhados por todo lado
é um sítio confortável pode se perguntar
então o futuro e as do futuro recuava
seu papel o papel já não tem papel bem
não é verdade
este gráfico que mostra a evolução do
papel da evolução do papel reciclado em
baixo
é uma emoção constante crescimento
constante que devia estar mais papel e o
que você ainda acha que vai trazer foi
ainda mais o papel porque eu ainda as
meninas computadores têm lá até mesmo um
exemplo histórico
é isso que nós estamos a fazer mais
papel é o caso o gráfico do consumo de
papel pode ser visto no gráfico do
desenvolvimento porque ela pensava 'não
não é muito envolvido necessário
associar parada mas tal estados unidos
com muitos envolve vivo e tal lei é
enfim precisar desenvolvimento ainda a
china é então temos uma maneira de ser
desenvolvidos reconquistar baixa pelo
que leio jornais comprar livros da
referida do livro porquê porque é o que
está a fazer china para desenvolver
portanto é o segredo
o futuro livros bibliotecas de papel e
também eletrônicas
a outra biblioteca é com isso termino
eweek tianjin na china
tura holandês e é extraordinário
cheia de livros também vai fae e cheia
de livros on perdia 2 milhões em que
livros em quilômetros distante e os
livros estão à beira de semear à beira
da guerra
eu termino da palavra caso saia do livro
o código da plataforma portuguesa e diz
assim carl sagan os livros permitem
viajar no tempo
o tema de hoje viajar no tempo dos
nossos antepassados que podem contar com
as concessões receber recursos trilhas
da natureza das maiores metas até hoje
existente com os novos professores
províncias todo o planeta e toda a nossa
história para nos inspirar em e nos dar
a nossa contribuição ao saber coletivo
da espécie humana saúde da nossa
civilização pode ser medida pelo apoio
que tivermos as nossas bibliotecas
obrigado
[Música]
[Aplausos]